bonsoir laurent segura vous êtes
l'épousé d'andré segura un ancien
braqueur site est unanimement comme un
exemple de réinsertion sociale père de
famille modèle tranquillement installé
dans le midi aujourd'hui réclamée par la
belgique pour des hold-up qu'il a commis
là bas en vertu de la loi perben 2 donc
la france est obligée d'extrader votre
mari a cédé faits qui remontent en cas
de 93 10 10 novembre 93 et cette loi est
rétroactive jusqu'à 93 - jusqu'au 1er au
10 novembre 93 ou quelques heures après
quoi à croire qu'ils ont fait cette loi
spécialement pour mon mari voilà et si
vous voulez dans d'autres pays
ce mandat d'arrêt européen ils remontent
jusqu'en 2000 2002 et c'est la france
qui le fait partir aussi loin que ça
déjà qu'un première interrogation la
relation que je me pose donc il se fait
arrêter au mois de juin
il est placé dans les qhs alors qu'il
est sorti par la grande porte
il est passé par neuf cour d'assises il
a payé sa dette disons à la société on
l'a libéré il a été surveillé il
travaille il travaille et il a réintégré
notre famille et nos deux filles et au
second tour il a fait dix jours de
détention et les juges de nîmes ont
décidé de le libérer
le procureur a fait cassation et là on
s'est retrouvé devant la cour de
cassation
on a été renvoyé à lyon alors alors
allez savoir je me pose deuxième point
d'interrogation
pourquoi lyon parce que normalement
étant de nîmes le 6 avignon montpellier
voire aix en provence mais jamais lyon
là on a été renvoyé à lyon hélas à lyon
a confirmé 1 voilà de le renvoyer huit
années
en belgique sachant que j'habite dans le
sud de la france alors là c'est ça
dépasse tout entendement c'est le coup
de massue qu'on a pris sur la tête le
coup de massue capri monsieur patrick
maranon son patron qui est totalement
révoltés parce que moi ça fait quand
même ça fait plus d'un an et demi qui
travaillaient avec mon mari qui lui a
même confié sur l'entreprise s'est
installée une confiance mais bosseur je
vais avec le parcours qu'on a eu
moi je me suis battue comme maintenir
mes liens familiaux parce qu'en france
on maintient rien du tout c'est dans
l'intérêt quand même de la société que
quelqu'un se réinsère ou à ce moment là
qu'ils fassent un poteau qui punch
enfants qui est un mec qui rentre au
lieu de construire de nouvelles prisons
qui vont bondé qui vont bien remplir je
peux vous le dire et le carrément le
fusiller voilà mon mari l'a pas de sang
sur les mains il a jamais tué personne
il n'a jamais même usé de violence ça a
été reconnue par neuf cour d'assises
lesquels des par des jurys populaires
ont décidé de procéder à ce qu'on
appelle à une confusion de peine pour
lui laisser sa chance
voilà alors on va raconter l'histoire ce
qu'on peut dire en tous les cas c'est
que votre mari qui s'est réinséré
totalement escompte il a vu ça quand il
a vu qu'il pouvait encore prendre huit
ans en belgique il est parti en cavale
est parti en cavale
il est ou pas je m'en sors bien bonnes
questions
j'ai malheureusement pas là il est pas
là cette cache ici voilà il fait du rab
oui voilà vous avez des nouvelles
missions avec les portables
oui ils nous appellent oui vous avez pas
peur qui repère mais si tu perds qui
leur père j'ai peur qu'ils arrêtent j'ai
peur qu'ils tombent sur un barrage il
s'arrêtera pas qu'ils se fassent tuer
parce que voilà avec un nouveau système
politique
il faut sérieusement vous avez retrouvé
vos anciens réflexes quoi sert la
méfiance voire avoir la parano quoi le
stress totalement et c'est ça c'est
horrible ce soir commente anne offert j
pas si on n'y pensait plus du tout quand
il s'est fini oui mais voilà voilà
et quand quand on m'a appelé et m'a dit
ton mari est en garde à vue alors vous
l'avez connu en fait vous aviez 18 ans 1
un jour il ya une copine qui vous dit
viens on va faire le guet devant une
banque
je ne savais pas où j'allais j'étais
petit et bon j'étais un peu à la rue
quoi parce que j'ai perdu ma maman
j'avais 16 ans et moi je vivais au jour
le jour je faisais un peu n'importe quoi
je me la faisait comme on dit avec un
peu n'importe qui et oui elle m'a dit
viens on va se balader donc je suis
parti avec elle effectivement je n'ai vu
arriver en main j'ai vu arriver deux
mecs en moto dont la chair est tendre et
et au départ je ne voulais pas du tout
quand j'ai vu ça ça m'a un le soir du
braquage il vous appelle et vous dis je
peux monter oui ils étaient en bas de
chez moi il m'a dit je peux monter j'ai
dit non et il me dit des métaux au
balcon il était à la cabine téléphonique
en batch ou un oui mais c'est vrai il
est monté et il est monté et le
lendemain la caisse d'epargne qui était
au pied de votre immeuble braquer
comment la wii
et c'était mon agence mais en plus c'est
votre pognon qu'il avait piqué alors là
j'ai un peu crié c'est pas sérieux moi
je dormais il partit le un matin et puis
j'ai entendu plein sirène vous demain
bwaba mais vraiment et puis je me suis
remis aux balkans et j'ai vu plein de
voitures arrivées de des policiers quoi
et là j'ai compris du style qu'est ce
qu'il a fait mais qu'est ce qui m'a fait
c'est possible et voilà quoi mais c'est
quand même un coup de foot parce que
vous l'avez plus quitté depuis quoi
ouais si on était sur la moto je suis
parent 1
alors ce qu'il faut dire en fait c'est
que votre mari c'est quand même un
gentleman quoi c'était un type qui a pas
de centre sur les marques dis ça parce
qu'il a jamais visé de violence moi j'ai
assisté à pratiquement toutes les cours
d'assises
1 et même des gens qui ont été pris en
otage par mon mari qui je m'assois côté
je ne savais pas qui c'était ki moon dit
bon châssis après je me dis oui mais je
suis là et puis c'est le roi de
l'évasion votre mari aussi il s'est fait
la belle vendrois absolument incroyable
quoi mais dès qu un pièce my way en
espagne et une prison là qu'on appelle
le alcatraz espagnol la cible chérie de
la serial en plein milieu du désert ici
km de désert
il restait dix jours là un dix jours
comment il a fait comment il fait cette
fois est d'accord mais disons qu'à nîmes
là la preuve la première évasion et
s'est passé avec volets tout simplement
avec les drames si le barreau pas si le
coût 450 dessiner la deuxième fois
il a deux fois il a filmé il a taillé
faux calibre dans le bois du tabouret
deux fois il a envoyé après le morceau
de bois en forme de ainsi romain calibre
il a envoyé mêmes journaux qu'il avait
photographié vous avez une vie
incroyable avec lui non on se rend pas
trop compte quand on est dans la dedans
ça on vit au jour le jour et un truc
rigolo c'est quand vous fuyez les
filatures par exemple vous rentrez dans
un grand magasin vous êtes en jean
pas maquillée pas coiffée oui vous allez
vous piquez noir et quand vous sortez
pour connaissent pas vous l'avez fait ça
oui
fan de x alors vous avez deux enfants
une première fille qui s'appelle sandra
et quand elle a 5 ans lui dit tu sais
ton papa est un braqueur
c'est son métier ses volets des banques
elle a réagi comment la petite baie à
bord elle ne réagit pas bon moi je ne
pars d'un principe c'est que les enfants
il faut pas leur mentir parce que sinon
après il arrive toujours à entendre des
choses ou avoir des même si on veut leur
cacher quelque chose est bon il faut pas
prendre les enfants pour des idiots et
je passe comme vraiment en leur disant
la vérité ça alors ça leur crée moins
d'angoissé tu
ouais ils peuvent pas si mal et pas
spécialement traumatisé aujourd'hui
alors en première littéraire l et par là
derrière
ah bon elle est dans le c'est vrai elle
est au salut est mignonne t'es pas
spécialement traumatisé son papa n'a
jamais tué l'écureuil comme quoi
ouais bravo vous êtes marié avec segura
donc en décembre 97 à la prison de
gradignan et là il décide de raccrocher
obligé de sans doute pour quelque chose
et de faire un deuxième enfant une
petite fille qui s'appelle talia oui
voilà oui parce que la cabale c'est pas
une vie
selon me faire quand même puis bon
il y en avait marre et puis bon il
savait que j'allais être là et puis que
pour granby quand on a des enfants il
faut aussi leur donner leur chance en
point voilà sept enfants pour vos
enfants vous le faites au parloir quoi
oui c'est ce qu'on appelle un parloir
sexuelle ouais oui c'est comment n'est
pas parce que celui-ci venant d'ailleurs
à gradignan
là où tout de maria fait la plupart de
sa peine il est sortie de gran en dix
ans est pratiquement six dans des boxes
et dans des couleurs cdc vitré on doit
tout quoi donc c'est ça fait 3 mètres
carrés il ya des petits bancs de chaque
côté donc voilà on a vécu notre vie
sexuelle
pendant des années je veux dire que ma
libido en a pris un coup quand même
voilà ça aussi à voilà et maintenant on
peut même plus s'asseoir sur les genoux
1 comment on fait les bébés ont fait
rien voilà fériés et les élèves ça
n'existe pas en france et là ils ont
fait 10 pas en arrière ces dernières
années depuis le nouveau gouvernement
ça ça s'arrête c'est l'horreur 6e la
droite veut pas qu'on baisse dans les
pays veulent pas qu'on les avait prises
au nom a le droit de se marier mais on
n'a pas le droit
alors je suis pas dans le code civil
je suis pas si vous tirez vous allez à
votre femme vous avez jugé puisqu'elle
vous dites que vous bref ma femme eve
pas bien je veux pas le divorce et à ses
torts un mariage et pas consommer c'est
pas un mariage quoi rester dans l'air
vous vous êtes arrivé à le consommer
dans des conditions périlleuses quand
même oui même à bois d'arcy
ah oui ah oui oui parce qu'en ce moment
il est en baisse à bois d'arcy je suis
la seule à bois d'arcy oui j'ai pas
honte de le dire à bonnart si c'était
fait exprès pour lui couper la chique et
là bas c'est carrément mais c'est que du
plexi c'est en rond à monsieur là ouais
non là bas vous avez gueuler pas ce que
vous dites mais moi j'ai ma vie autour
de grâce vous le dis à 4 heures du matin
pour vendre des fleurs sur les marchés
aux besoins de votre mari et un jour on
l'emmène à bois d'arcy et lave toute
votre vie a recommencé y rester trois
mois bon ben il revenu après à gradignan
et il a fini sa peine il est sorti de
gradignan
il a fait dix ans de prison il a payé sa
dette à la société quand il est sorti il
est devenu technicien informatique dans
une société qui s'appelle etc au micro
ça s'est super bien passé rapidement il
est devenu cadre et puis un jour son
patron lui a demandé d'aller monter une
filiale de cette société anime donc
c'est un bon élément
c'était une très bonne et les mains son
patron dit même qu'il a sauvé
l'entreprise à bordeaux parce qu'il en a
une aussi à toulouse il va faire aussi
sur paris voilà alors vous vous avez
lutté pendant des années pour arriver à
ça c'est à dire être avec votre mari vos
deux enfants à la limite métro boulot
dodo pour vous c'était un rêve
non pas du tout une punition on peut
dire il avait échappé à la voyoucratie
il était un exemple de réinsertion cité
dans les médias
et puis voilà la belgique leur éclat la
loi perben 2 fait qu'il peut y retourner
mois il ay là on n'a rien à voir en plus
à 2 dans la première fois qu'il est
rentré en prison il avait déjà rien à
voir avec l'histoire qu'on lui
reprochait il a fait 20 mois de
détention provisoire avant de ceux de
cbd avec son frère aîné et il n'avait
pas d'autre choix il n'avait pas de
parloir le juge s'acharner sur lui hélas
ces deux nouveau-nés reparti au début
quoi parce que la 93 nous on était plus
en belgique on était plus en belgique
il a été jugé il n'était pas là et si
c'est une consommables ça je sais qu'ils
avaient collé cette affaire sur un autre
français un que je peux pas citer son
nom ici donc c'est pas ce france elle a
eu un non-lieu bombe segura il est passé
par là on va lui coller à lui - et non
il n'était plus là bah ouais voilà
et ça s'il ya une enquête mais là ils
veulent même pas ouvrir le dossier
lorsque terrible en plus c'est ce qu'il
fallait pas revenir sur leurs erreurs à
faire je sais pas ça à faire il veut pas
passer pour des couillons
voilà alors c'était dans cette histoire
c'est la petite talia qui accueille six
ans et noir et qui dit à son père tu
m'avais promis que tout retournerai
jamais en prison
c'est ça le plus dur jourdain jamais si
c'est ça c'est ça qui me met la haine
quoi
parce que sont derrière leur bureau se
rendent pas compte qu'ils fassent des
lois je suis d'accord je m'en fous en
bref royalement je m'en fous au nom de
la coordination européenne judiciaire
pour le pour le terrorisme ça a été fait
au départ pour les disparitions
d'enfants
je suis tout à fait d'accord là dessus
il aurait dû le faire même avant voilà
mais qui nous lâchent en quoi moi ça
m'amuse pas de venir sur des plateaux de
télé qu'on me reconnaisse dans la rue et
qui me lâche
pendant deux ans j'ai plus militer j'ai
plus emmerdé personne j'ai pu ramener ma
gueule nulle part mais qui nous foutent
la paix et non il faut qu'ils me le
prenne qui me le replonge dans les qhs
avec comme motif s'est évadé date il ya
quelques années à 18 ans en arrière
quand même hein et colas maintenant on
veut me l'envoyer en belgique pour huit
ans ici croyez que je vais rien faire et
ça veut dire qu'un peu de réinsertion
peu sinon voilà non puissent y croyaient
pas la réinsertion mais ça n'existe pas
la réinsertion les déconner quand on a
contacté tout ça c'est des mensonges
c'est des conneries
qu'est ce que vous comptez faire là pour
pour poser votre mari dénoncé au maximum
que les gens que l'opinion publique
qu'ils arrêtent de ces c'est grave ce
qui se passe à ce moment parce que moi
moi moi quand j'ai connu la prison je
croyais je ne savais pas la prison ce
que c'est et je crois que c'est dans un
autre pays c'est là à côté de chez nous
alors on parle des autres pays dessine
les tortures tout ce qu'il peut se
passer dans les prisons dans les gardes
à vue déjà si vous saviez ce qui se
passe c'est l'horreur absolue
on parle du nazisme à ce moment ni qu'on
aille faire un peu un tour j'ai vu un
député a pas longtemps j'ai miami et ya
mis un pied dans une prison ah oui on va
vous la faire visiter mais alors là où
fait on va aller choisir les cellules on
va vous faire dans vous faire parler le
débit des tenues choisies aussi parce
que si elle n'avait qu'à le malheur de
l'ouvrir je peux vous dire qu'il va se
fait taper dessus quand on vend de
prison c'est qu'on a commis un délit
qu'on n'a pas respecté la loi
mais les prisons il ya eu un constat
l'assemblée nationale c'est pas moi qui
le dit c'est des zones de non-droit des
zones de non droit moi j étais en prison
jamais passer devant le tribunal j'ai
jamais volé une petite cuillère jamais
eu ni un jour de prison avec sursis
pourtant m'a mis deux fois en prison ma
fille à ses quatre mois et demi de
prison
elle a fait 5 jours de garde à vue alors
qu'à l'époque c'était 48 heures la garde
à vue
comment expliquer ça alors si haut si on
est là pour pour payer quelque chose
parce qu'on a fait des conneries
il faut au moins que ce soit reste que
que il respecte le les droits c'est pour
ça que je me suis mise à militer pour
m'aider à supporter la situation
la séparation de mon mari et de
plusieurs personnes qui militent avec
plusieurs femmes de nord de prises pas
militer parce que de suite dès que vous
même faire signer une pétition
la première punition si le transfert sur
le détenu s'est les brimades sur
brimades c'est celle en faire à l'époque
du nazisme
il y avait des gens monstrueux se dit
comment il ya des gens qui peuvent faire
des choses comme ça faut pas croire
qu'ils existent plus ces gens là c'est
pas parce qu'on n'est pas en guerre ou
laisser les plus pervers lisent ils sont
là mais se cache derrière des beaux
costards et je peux vous dire ouais
alors après on se demande oui le bon et
le mauvais moi je me pose la question
parce que ce qui est terrible c'est que
il a fait ça en belgique et donc la
belgique avec le mandat d'arrêt européen
aujourd'hui peut le réclamer
alors que l'italie n'a pas accepter ça
voilà c'est par anita dit s'il avait
fait ces braquages en italie tu tentes
et qui les effets utilisés avait fait en
italie
il serait pas emmerder c'est
complètement surréaliste et c'est de la
folie tu vas quitter la france et a pas
d'autre solution pour garder la liberté
de ton mari à la tienne mais bon je ma
fille qui en première l là elle a un
petit copain qui adorable
c'est ma petite et les loisirs voilà
c'est voilà tout et puis bon quand on
n'a pas le franc comme on fait quoi tu
peux pas m'en a pas tous montés dans la
voiture et partir comme ça comme alan 40
quoi moi ce que j'espère c'est qu'ils
trouvent un arrangement et qui me lâche
la grappe quoi qui me qui nous lâchent
qui nous laisse bosser tranquille vous
pensez que le fait de remettre ce que je
vais vous dire quand je me suis enchaîné
ça va parler ça va pas coûter grand
chose de machines et j'ai pas risquer ni
ma vie dit rien mais alors c'était juste
l'entrée après va venir le reste quoi
l'asim là je peux vous dire que je pense
qu'à ça je tourne je viens j'ai perdu 8
kilos je suis pas bien mais je
trouverais quoi croyez moi je suis dans
mon bon droit
je suis dans mon bon droit j'ai rien à
me reprocher mon mari il a été libéré
les sorties par la grande porte
il a rien à se reprocher mais bon voilà
en tous les cas tu peux venir ici pour
en parler chaque fois que tu veux merci
d'accord
tenez plus en parler voilà j'ai plus
envie d'en parler parce que la prise en
main que le mot prison à sa mort on peut
dire ton mail mais qu'un intrus qui est
positif là-dedans c'est la force de
notre amour pour lui c'est sûr ces
substrats ordinaire comment voulez mais
là mais je n'ai pas écouté j'ai pas
trouvé mieux après 18h avec lui j'ai
encore pas trouvé c'est bien d'aller
vécu combien de temps ensemble sur 18 en
disant m 85,4 me semble neuf en disant
et si c'était à refaire pareil
ben vous de l'amour j'aimerais bien être
à sa place en tout cas c'est vrai je me
dis encore avait très bien comme ça
c'est un shérif en jeu et pour être sûr
de ne rien rater de dinars 10 tubes
abonnez vous je m'étais 1 pouces bleus